sans doute le plus prestigieux vin du
monde le château yquem produit au coeur
de sauternes selon une tradition vieille
de 300 ans
voyage dans les coulisses du fameux
château à l'occasion des vendanges éric
perrin bernard bonne arme une histoire
de temps qui passe une affaire de
patience et de savoir faire
vendanges à yquem le plus prestigieux
des vins de sauternes depuis cinq
semaines la troupe passe et repasse dans
les mêmes rangs de vigne à la recherche
du raisin idéal
cb attaqué par un champignon le botrytis
en persan la peau il favorise
l'évaporation du jus la concentration
des sucres et des arômes
voici le secret des vins liquoreux la
pourriture noble dès ce stade on peut le
déguster une expérience extraordinaire
confits confitures point je les supplie
pressoir mou puis premières
fermentations sandrine maître de chai
vérifie à l'oreille que la naissance se
passe bien ce qu'on entend là c'est le
bruit de la fermentation alcoolique donc
la transformation du moût de raisin
enfin après la naissance
l'élevage là encore une histoire de
temps le vin d'yquem passe trois ans et
demi en fût de chêne
il va y gagner en complexité sandrine
vient régulièrement goûter chacune de
ses 1200 barriques
on pourrait penser quand on complète
blasé de déguster régulièrement ses vins
la maintenance sont des vins qui
surprennent tout au long de leur vie
depuis six générations la famille du
comte de lur saluces conduit la destinée
du château moment rare visite du caveau
rassemblant les plus vieux millésimes
parfois l'histoire d'yquem croise
l'histoire tout court une date 1787 des
initiales grave était agi thomas
jefferson
cette bouteille appartenu à l'un des
premiers présidents des états unis des
trésors sans prix pouvant dépasser aux
enchères les 30000 euros
incroyable alchimie du temps ce 1892 et
paraît-il encore subli c'est lambres on
arrive à des couleurs de certaines
pierres précieuses la couleur peut faire
peur à des non initiés
les initiés savent que ça n'a pas de
signification encore au bout et que ça
peut être tout à fait délicieux
depuis le xviiie siècle yquem est plus
qu'un vin une oeuvre d'art pour la
petite histoire il faut un pied de vigne
pour produire un verre de ce nectar